this video has been made possible by one
trim
[Music]
what
Dior the dress
not just your house number or the name
of your street
where actually are you in a town or a
city which is in a country on a
continent on Earth
but where
is Earth
whites in the solar system between Venus
and Mars you might say
where
is that
the solar system is the main part of the
art cloud a vast collection of comets
asteroids and icy objects swirling at
the fringes of the sun's sphere of
influence the Oort cloud resides in the
local Interstellar Cloud which is in the
local cavity of the Orion arm of the
Milky Way galaxy The Milky Way is a
spiral galaxy with beautiful sweeping
arms of millions upon millions of stars
all rotating around a bright Galactic
core with a dark supermassive black hole
at its Center at over a hundred thousand
light years across the Milky Way is vast
but it is still just a sliver of what we
can see zoom out further and you will
see a local group with 30 to 50 small
galaxies and a monster on a collision
course the Andromeda galaxy twice the
size of the Milky Way Andromeda is
speeding towards us we will collide in a
few billion years tearing each other
apart before coalescing into one but
when you zoom out even further the
impending Collision of two galaxies
seems inconsequential at the scale of
millions of light years the structure of
the Virgo supercluster a collection of
thousands of galaxies becomes apparent
and dwarfing even that is the Lanier
chaos supercluster hundreds of millions
of light years across containing several
other superclusters like our Virgo and
which is itself part of the Pisces cetus
supercluster complex a galactic filament
almost a billion light years long
and it is now that the cosmic web
becomes visible there are more filaments
like our own as well as great strings of
superclusters there are also giant
stretches of space with virtually
nothing in them
like the booties void an area 330
million light years across in which we
have discovered barely 60 galaxies
an inkblot on the speckled sky
zooming out further we finally reach the
edge of the observable universe where
primordial light has been traveling
since nearly the beginning of time 13.8
billion years to reach our eyes
but since then of course the universe
has expanded further meaning that the
true distance to the edge is about 46
billion light years in One Direction
meaning the full observable universe is
a sphere 93 billion light years in
diameter
[Music]
structures any larger than a few billion
light years are hard to Define without
current technology partially because we
are trying to map something we inhabit
and partially because there may well be
a limit something scientists call the
end of greatness but at every level up
to this point planets solar systems
galaxies clusters superclusters
universe is full of structure it is not
a random and chaotic jumble it seems
organized yet the universe started as a
hot dense soup of particles why should
it now be structured why did that hot
soup evolve into a universe where some
parts are filled with beautiful sweeping
arms of stars While others are Barren
deserts
and more importantly
how do we know
how did we start this channel to begin
with a lot of research and in-depth
exploration of the universe's first
moments and a huge part of that was done
through wondriam the educational
subscription service and I'm not
exaggerating wandrium used to be called
Great Courses plus which made University
level lecture series and they've now
expanded to contain even more content
from travelogues and tutorials to
long-form documentaries wandrium is now
the best place for all your high quality
enjoyable content that is guaranteed to
make you smarter one great example of
this is Sean Carroll's Peerless lecture
series Dark Matter Dark Energy I am
currently on my third listen through and
I learned something new each time 24
half hour cosmology lectures given by
the best science Communicator out there
for example it really helped me
understand the reasoning behind the
theory of inflation just superb and only
one of many other courses on offer I'm
not exaggerating when I say that without
wandrium this channel may not have
existed it is the best educational
subscription service out there and
they're giving viewers a great offer of
a free trial so get the Fantastic
education I did by heading over to
wandrium.com forward slash history of
the universe thanks to wandrium for
education on YouTube
the year is 1502 and Nicolaus Copernicus
should be studying medicine in Padua it
is the Center for Medical Education in
Europe all the best teachers and
students gather there to learn how to
heal the sick but Nicolaus is a polymath
he is learning medicine but he's also
reading Aristotle and Plutarch and Plato
and finding holes in ptolemy's theories
in his spare time finishing his degree
he returns home to Poland to work as a
physician for his father though he
doesn't forget about the cosmos or our
place in it and so it is a decade later
that he writes a pamphlet outlining his
now ubiquitous Theory we are not the
center of the universe the Earth orbits
the sun just like all the other planets
we are not special niklaus knows the
Uproar this will cause so he doesn't
publish right away it is only in his
70th year some say it's actually on
deathbed that he proves the final copy
that the book finally comes out a shakes
the very foundations of science
astronomy philosophy and religion an
idea so dangerous and Fantastical that
its proponents would be persecuted for
decades after its publication
the heretical notion that our Earth is
just the third planet among many
at the time it was a shocking thought
but it marked only the beginning of a
larger Revelation for if we are just
some Planet orbiting a random star what
does that make us not
special it's a sad realization at first
but when we think deeper it opens up a
world of possibilities if we are not
special
what else is out there who else is out
there
to discover known as the copernican
principle the idea is now a Bedrock of
modern cosmology and has two related
tenets the Earth is not special we don't
occupy some privileged position in the
universe therefore observations from the
earth should be relatively
representative of observations from
anywhere one modern day discovery that
backed up this claim was the detection
of the cosmic microwave background or
the CMB a fuzzy background static it
permeates the sky no matter in which
direction you look no matter how
powerful your telescope if you keep
zooming in on a part of the sky with
nothing in it you will still detect
faint microwave radiation always with
almost the same wavelength emitted at a
time close to the beginning of the
universe at the moment when Mata cooled
down enough for protons to capture
electrons and become clear gas it is
everywhere in this regard our bit of the
universe is clearly not special outer
space no matter which direction you look
has a temperature of about 2.7 degrees
Kelvin it doesn't matter if you are
floating in outer space near the Milky
Way or past distant Methuselah the
average temperature of empty space is
about the same
but there is an obvious issue with this
and one that doesn't require a
high-powered telescope to recognize
our Cosmic address is full of huge
structures galaxies super clusters Great
Walls of stars hundreds of millions of
light years across and great voids with
nothing in them
the universe clearly isn't totally
uniform
we aren't special
but there are structures
all large-scale structure in the
universe can be explained by two
opposing forces expansion and gravity
the universe started hot and dense and
then underwent three phases of expansion
the first lasted a fraction of a second
and was extreme this is called inflation
it then continued to expand in a second
stage for several billion years at a
more reasonable rate cooling down
spreading out and slowing its expansion
and in the last few billion years it has
entered the third stage in which
expansion has accelerated again and so
what is responsible for these shifting
regimes of expansion the initial
inflation has been theorized to have
been caused by a mysterious field called
the inflaton the latter expansion a
mysterious energy so baffling it's
simply known as dark energy in truth we
don't know for sure but what we are sure
of is the existence of gravity which has
spent billions of years battling against
the quickening expansion when a part of
the early Universe became a bit denser
that over density attracted more matter
which consequently made it more massive
and so gravity acted even stronger to
bring more matter in clouds of dust and
gas became Stars which clumped into
galaxies and so on
it was and is gravity doing what gravity
does at its most basic level
problem solved
but not quite
can't start this process with a totally
even universe
just where did the first over densities
come from
[Music]
the best dancers we have now started to
be revealed with space telescopes in the
late 1980s and the race to map the
entire universe to higher and higher
resolution the cosmic background
Explorer Kobe was launched from
Vandenberg Air Force Base in Southern
California by NASA in 1989. the Cold War
was ending and a new era of cooperation
between Global superpowers was about to
begin and what better way to start this
New Era than the first baby picture of
the universe Kobe had a bold Mission
take detailed images of the entire
celestial sphere and tell us how uniform
the background radiation really is and
so on April the 24th 1992 the results
were plastered on the front page of the
New York Times scientists report
profound Insight on how time began Kobe
had mapped tiny variations
anisotropies in the cosmic microwave
background radiation they were very
small just one part in a hundred
thousand but they were there this
Blockbuster result won two Nobel prizes
in 2006 for two of the lead astronomers
on the telescope John C Matha and George
F Smoot with the Nobel committee marking
it as the birth of cosmology as a
precise science
success of Kobe LED NASA to launch
another telescope in 2001 called the
Wilkinson microwave and isotropy probe
or w-map this further proved the
Blockbuster capabilities of space
telescopes and instead of a vague smear
of under and overdense regions wmap was
able to tell fine structure and patterns
started to emerge so again in 2009 the
Planck satellite was launched by the
European Space Agency to get an even
better picture of the baby Universe each
successive experiment kept demonstrating
the same principle there were tiny
fluctuations in the very early Universe
which after being stretched out by
expansion and clumped by gravity led to
the structures we see today
and there are dozens of other
experiments telescopes and satellites
each discovering and mapping new parts
of this structure
back on Earth one of the best telescopes
for mapping the universe is the Sloan
digital Sky survey perched on a mountain
in New Mexico this telescope creates a
map of the whole sky in an unusual way
first the astronomers take a regular
Optical image then they create an
aluminum plate with a precise hole
drilled for each star or other
astronomical object in the image they
then run a fiber optic cable from each
of the holes in the plate to
spectrographs so they can find the
colors of the stars and therefore find
out how far away they are and how fast
they're moving these rainbow collecting
aluminum plates are each custom drilled
and capture a unique slice of the
universe so far over ten thousand plates
have been drilled
by combining data from different surveys
astronomers managed to Define Lanier Kea
our local supercluster
home a group of thousands of galaxies
all bound together by gravity and our
universe maps are filled with many more
Fantastical places of course stretching
out from our own local group of galaxies
is the Virgo supercluster whose tendrils
Connect into The Centaurus supercluster
beyond that is the Perseus Pisces
supercluster and the South Pole wall
which stretches across over a billion
light years and the Sloan Great Wall is
about 1 billion light years in the other
direction an equally Mammoth structure
and some astronomers believe that the
Milky Way and a large part of Lani Ikea
actually reside within another
supermassive void known as KBC proposed
to be almost 2 billion light years in
diameter though its existence is still
hotly debated and even these have been
dwarfed by a recent discovery the giant
Ark was discovered in 2021 and is about
9 billion light years away it is thought
to span 3.1 billion light years three
and a half percent of the observable
Cosmos and is so huge it actually
challenges our assumptions about the
Universe on the largest scales
if you zoom all the way out a pattern
appears filaments tie together into
walls and clusters with large voids
hanging between them
but what is the structure of this web is
it like meatballs of matter in a soup of
emptiness or pancakes of matter arranged
at jaunty angles
surprisingly answering this seemingly
ridiculous question which kitchen
metaphor does the large-scale structure
of our universe most resemble would
obsess the field of cosmology for
decades
truth pride and Nobel prizes were at
stake
at the largest scales is the universe
like a meatball soup a honeycomb or a
sponge
foreign
veteran of the Soviet Atomic program
sits in his office in Moscow
contemplating the universe
how did the large-scale structure of the
universe arise he asks himself perhaps
his contemplations make him hungry for
lunch
on the other side of the world a
mild-mannered Canadian sits in his
office in Princeton contemplating the
universe
how do tiny particles become huge
galaxies similarly hunger-inducing
thoughts so perhaps he wanders down to
the cafeteria for a break
the name of the astronomer in America is
Jim Peebles he would eventually win the
Nobel Prize in physics in 2019 for
theoretical discoveries in physical
cosmology he and others of the American
School believe that matter in the
universe was organized like meatballs in
a low-density soup Mata would attract
Mata which would attract more mass
clumping together in roughly spherical
assemblies leaving vast areas of low
density this was a bottom-up approach
the large-scale structure gets formed by
clumping smaller scale structures
meanwhile behind the Iron Curtain Soviet
astronomers were busy developing their
own Theory Yakov zeldevich was the
Russian musing on the cosmos by the
1970s he was a renowned physicist who
had cut his teeth in the Soviet nuclear
program before turning his attention to
the large-scale structure of the
universe he had developed a theory where
the density in the universe was
organized in 2D pancakes and where the
pancakes overlapped you would have
Galaxy formation in this way the
large-scale structure comes first and
galaxies are formed from them in
zeldovich's Universe there are large
empty voids with filaments on the edges
of Pancakes and clusters where pancakes
intersect
zeldevich was a brilliant scientist with
a lot of sway in the Soviet Union but
because of his role he was rarely if
ever permitted to leave the USSR his
ideas therefore took longer to
disseminate than they might have
otherwise and so at the height of the
Cold War you had Jim Peebles a
soft-spoken Canadian Living in the USA
advocating for a universe dominated by
meatball clumps and the Russian School
led by a hardened veteran of the Soviet
Atomic program believing in the pancake
model meatballs versus pancakes there's
no evidence of animosity between the two
but without hard data each stuck to
their own beliefs but luckily between
them was an unlikely interloper Martin
Reese an English astronomer Who Would
One Day become the UK's astronomer Royal
he acted as a sort of go-between for the
American and Russian schools the English
were more permissive about which
meetings they were allowed to attend
than either the Americans or the
Russians and so Reese's post-doc a man
from Kentucky named Richard Gott then
developed a third theory that better
matches the findings of later
experiments like the Sloan digital Sky
survey got met zeldovich at a conference
in Estonia then part of the USSR in 1977
and this meeting along with developments
in observation would lead to a new
understanding of the universe as
recounted by God in his book The Cosmic
web zeldovich was a character always use
the median he said in Russia the watches
are not made very well so when friends
get together they compare the times on
their watches one says 5 minutes to five
another says five o'clock the other says
11 o'clock use the median
inspired by the brilliant Soviet got
would develop a new Theory
the universe is like a sponge the
topology of God's Universe lies
conceptually between the American
meatballs and the Russian pancakes
according to him high density and low
density regions are connected and
complementary in other words you could
switch high density for low density and
it would be the same
[Music]
as new maps like those from the Sloan
digital Sky survey became available this
is the structure that was observed
neither meatballs nor pancakes
but a sponge but this is not everything
that our telescopes have seen as our
methods of scanning the skies have
improved and we have seen further and
further back in time with increasing
detail
something strange has been observed
a phenomena referred to by some as the
end of greatness at around a billion
light years the universe finally becomes
homogeneous the same everywhere
large-scale structure
disappears
why
[Music]
imagine you are in Ecuador standing on
the equator look up in the night sky
with a powerful telescope and observe
the cosmic microwave background
radiation in all of its Majesty take a
careful measurement of its temperature
now fly to Indonesia on the equator on
the exact opposite side of the Earth
and look up if you take a careful
measurement of the temperature of the
CMB you'll find it matches the
measurement you took in Ecuador the
light from each point took about 14
billion years to reach you meaning the
points would now be 28 billion light
years apart except that space has been
expanding in the intervening years so
they're really much farther away than
that and yet the universe is only about
13.8 billion years old to put it simply
there hadn't been enough time for the
light that you saw in Indonesia to have
reached the light you saw in Ecuador so
how could they possibly be the same
temperature how could they know what
temperature to agree on if they couldn't
thermodynamically talk to each other
perhaps it's a coincidence so you pick
two other random points in the sky they
will also match temperature to within
one part in a hundred thousand
this is the Horizon problem when you
look at the microwave background
radiation it is extremely uniform when
you look at colorful images from
experiments like wmap or Planck the
color differences are deceptive the
differences between red and blue are
actually tiny they are differences of
one part in a hundred thousand for
almost all intents and purposes
that's the same temperature
and so this poses a fundamental physical
challenge and it is one of the reasons
for the development of the idea of
inflation
the theory proposed by Alan Guth in the
1980s is that there must have been some
very rapid expansion in the early
Universe with inflation parts of the
universe that are now separated by
unimaginable distances could have been
in very close proximity in the past but
in order for inflation to solve the
Horizon problem the expansion would have
to have taken place much faster than the
speed of light this may seem
counter-intuitive because of the
universal speed limit of light but that
only applies to matter and energy within
the universe space itself doesn't need
to obey this speed limit in fact due to
the rate of expansion of the universe
space today is still expanding faster
than the speed of light two galaxies
more than 15 to 20 billion light years
apart would be moving away from each
other faster than light this means that
the part of the universe you saw in
Indonesia and the part you saw in
Ecuador used to be much closer together
so close in fact that they could
equilibrate and calls the haze of
uniformity that we see when we look out
but of course inflation is an
extraordinary claim for which
extraordinary evidence is required and
definitive observational proof for this
Theory remains elusive despite this
indirect proof continues to pile up
which makes inflation an attractive
Theory as we know a universe that
underwent inflation would be homogeneous
which on large scales ours is an
inflationary Universe would also be flat
which ours appears to be this flatness
refers not to the number of Dimensions
but instead to the effect of the density
of matter and energy in the universe
cosmologists can measure the shape of
the universe in two independent ways
first they can count up all the mass and
energy in the universe and divide it by
the critical energy density the density
at which the universe would be flat and
they can also measure it geometrically
by measuring angles on a positively
curved sphere like the earth a try angle
drawn on the surface will have angles
that add up to more than 180 degrees the
3D geometry of the universe would be
closed like this if it had more stuff in
it eventually gravity would pull
everything together into a big crunch in
a universe with less stuff in it
expansion would continue forever and
space would be hyperbolic in a flat
universe straight lines and angles make
sense triangles have angles that add up
to 180 degrees results from both types
of experiment show that what we have is
a flat universe another plus point for
inflation and so this is strong evidence
for the theory but how then did
inflation work to make the universe we
see one of almost perfect homogeneity
but not exactly perfect
much of course can be gleaned from the
universe's baby picture the CMB which
shows us the after effects of very early
fluctuations in density in the early
universe but anything before the CMB is
obscured by the fact that everything was
too hot for light to travel in straight
lines excited electrons kept getting in
the way and inflation is supposed to
have happened within a tiny fraction of
a second after the birth of the universe
and so there are nearly 380
000 years of physics that are hidden by
the haze of Three Degree radiation where
did these early fluctuations seen in the
CMB come from it's easy to point at a
tree and explain that it grew from a
seed
but where
did the seed come from
[Music]
imagine a box
with nothing in it
close the lid so no light can get in
take all the air out with a pump and
seal it cool it down to absolute zero
insulate it with lead so no radiation
can penetrate is it empty
no
the universe is a fundamentally noisy
place there is no such thing as truly
empty space even if there were no matter
Inside the Box space is always permeated
by Quantum Fields with different values
at different positions one of these
fields the Higgs field gives things Mass
another the electromagnetic field gives
things charge and Carries light
one of the big discoveries of early
modern physics by the likes of
Heisenberg Einstein and Planck was the
inherent noisiness of the universe there
is uncertainty at the smallest scales
which shows up as a faint buzz in the
quantum fields at the quantum level even
empty space is filled with Quantum
Fields whose values are varying randomly
but why is this important for the
large-scale structure of the universe to
answer that question
we have to go back to the very start
in the beginning the observable universe
was hot dense and Tiny the also tiny
Quantum fluctuations were buzzing along
with very small differences in the
roiling patchwork of energy Fields as
they do today and then suddenly and
dramatically inflation the universe
rapidly expanded by 26 orders of
magnitude in a tiny fraction of a second
changes this extreme are hard to
describe we don't have the words to
properly conjure the scale of this
explosion in our heads 26 orders of
magnitude is a grain of sand one
millimeter across expanding to a
septillion meters across that's 100
million light years something on the
scale of laniacaya and the violence of
this detonation was staggering in 10 to
the minus 33 seconds the observable
universe went from microscopic to huge
for all intents and purposes the
expansion was instantaneous and so this
inflation Amplified the quantum noise of
the vacuum into genuine differences in
density thus giving gravity all it
needed to work its attractive Magic
Gathering Mass together into Stars
galaxies super clusters and filaments
these variations would have been the
first seeds inconceivably tiny Quantum
fluctuations the forefathers of vast
Intergalactic filaments many millions of
light years in length tiny acorns
growing into vast forests
but that is not the end of the story
[Music]
after inflation was complete the
universe continued to expand and cool
down but it remained extremely hot and
dense if the large-scale structure of
the universe were purely shaped by the
expansion of quantum fluctuations you
would expect everything to be
distributed fairly randomly indeed if
you look at a population of galaxies and
ask how far each Galaxy is from each
other galaxy in the population you
should see a simple relationship and
regular clustering galaxies would tend
to be fairly close together because of
the clumping effect of gravity and so
you should be thus and less likely to
find two galaxies separated by larger
distances and yet this is not what
astronomers see when they do do this
kind of analysis they observe one Peak
for Galaxies that are close together as
expected and another one for a
separation of about 150 megaparsecs what
explains this overabundance at what
seems like an arbitrary distance
the answer lies in what's known as
baryon acoustic oscillations Galaxy
dwarfing sound waves
the hundreds of thousands of years after
the big bang it was too hot for Atomic
nuclei to capture electrons the universe
was a sea of charged particles and
photons of light couldn't travel in
straight lines they would get bounced
around scattering in every direction
until they hit the next stray electron
as it cooled some of the regions that
were more dense would pull more and more
stuff in but photons exert a pressure
when they get too close together and
this pressure would push out carrying
some matter with it and this is where
Dark Matter entered the picture Dark
Matter outweighs regular matter in the
universe by five times it was and
Remains the dominant gravitational force
in our universe the cosmic web of stars
galaxies and filaments is really a web
of dark matter with regular matter
tagging along it accounts for something
like 85 percent of the gravity in the
universe so everything from Galaxy
formation to Stark clustering and
gravitational then Zing is dictated by
its properties and yet we still don't
know what it really is what we do know
is that dark matter interacts
gravitationally but doesn't seem to be
affected by electromagnetism such as
light or the other fundamental forces so
as clumps of density began to form in
the early Universe the photons would
eventually get squeezed so much that
they would burst out in a ferocious wave
of plasma carrying some regular matter
also known as baryons but leaving the
Dark Matter behind in the center imagine
a pebble dropped in a pool there is a
central Splash and then concentric rings
of ripples now imagine millions of
Pebbles dropped at slightly different
times it would create a complex jumble
of splashes Ripples and regions where
the Rings interacted this was the state
of the universe after inflation but the
universe was Cooling and once it reached
3000 Kelvin protons were able to capture
electrons and the phase changed instead
of a bubbling opaque plasma it became a
transparent gas the moment the universe
became transparent the cosmic microwave
background radiation escaped and the
expanding Rings suddenly stopped because
the photons that were carrying the
matter were no longer coupled with that
matter the photons rushed off in a
straight line leaving the ring Frozen at
the distance it had reached and that
distance is 150 megaparsecs exactly
where we see the second bump in the
graph of Galaxy separations
this is one of the ways that
cosmologists can see past the CMB by
deciphering the patterns in its
seemingly random distribution dark
matter is Central to this story and
indeed the structuring of the universe
that followed in fact in a lot of ways
dark matter is the true main character
in The Narrative of the universe and yet
they almost completely undetected until
the mid-20th century
back in 1933 a young and ambitious Swiss
astronomer named Fritz Vicky noticed
something odd about the speed of stars
in a galaxy he observed the two
independent measures of the mass of a
cluster of galaxies weren't lining up if
he counted up all the stars and added
their Mass he got a number 10 times less
than if he instead calculated the mass
by looking at the speeds of the galaxies
in the cluster he thus concluded that
there must be an enormous amount of
unseen Mass
however it would be more than 30 years
before further Evidence would come to
light as pioneering astronomer Vera
Rubin set her sights on spiral galaxies
in predicting the Motions of stars
around the center of galaxies
astronomers had always made three
assumptions one gravity depends on
distance and mass the closer and more
massive two objects are the stronger
gravity acts on them 2. spiral galaxies
have most of their stars in the very
bright Central regions and three stars
on the edge of galaxies would have less
gravity acting on them and would travel
more slowly this is analogous to our own
solar system most of the mass is
contained in the Sun so the close
planets like Mercury Venus and Earth
travel much faster than the gas giant
Saturn Uranus and Neptune so imagine
Vera rubin's surprise when she observed
the speeds of stars in nearby spiral
galaxies she found the relationship
between speed and distance traced a
straight line in her graph instead of
acting like the solar system the stars
on the edges of spiral galaxies traveled
just as fast as those in their cause and
so there was a fourth hidden assumption
that astronomers were making which
Reuben made explicit
while it was true that spiral galaxies
have most of their stars in the central
regions Stars don't account for most of
the mass in order to account for this
increased speed normal matter Stars dust
nebulae could only account for 15 of the
total matter in the universe
so what was this dark matter the leading
theory currently is w-i-m-p's weekly
interacting massive particles these
would be Elementary particles like
protons or neutrons but would have
peculiar properties unlike protons which
have a charge and interact with light
these wimps would be invisible and only
interact with gravity there would also
need to be much heavier or much more
numerous in order to make up for the
missing mass in the universe today we
know that all galaxies accept some dwarf
Galaxies have larger Halos of Dark
Matter surrounding them scientists
estimate that the Milky Way's hay though
could extend up to 15 times further than
the matter we can see searches for these
particles at particle colliders like the
Large Hadron Collider in Switzerland are
giant Vats of noble gases in Antarctica
and other places have so far come up
without definitive proof for the wimp
Theory but scientists are hopeful as
dark matter explains so much about the
large-scale structure of the universe it
makes everything make sense The Echoes
of baryonic shock waves the speeds of
galaxies and the patterns of clustering
in the growth of structure Across the
Universe normal matter what we see and
what we are is only really a bit player
the main role in building the Universe
goes to this mysterious invisible stuff
foreign
minuscule Quantum fluctuations to Galaxy
dwarfing sound waves and finally vast
tides of Dark Matter our webbed Universe
was born
problem solved not quite there are
further structural Mysteries out there
Mysteries we haven't even begun to
unravel
we are all moving in the same direction
we're spinning on the earth which is
revolving around the sun which is
spiraling around the Galaxy which itself
has motion but zooming much further out
all the galaxies around us in laniacaya
are pulled towards the same point in
space we are all moving in the same
direction
but where are we going
a scientist studied the CMB for the
first time it became clear that our
local group of galaxies was not
stationary it was moving relative to the
CMB in fact we are rushing at around 1
000 kilometers a second towards a point
250 million light years away and this
point was dubbed the great attractor
but what was there why this particular
point and not somewhere else if
according to the copernican principle no
point in space is more special than any
other why should so much mass move
towards this this spot we didn't know
then and we still aren't sure
One Challenge was that whatever we were
heading for was very hard to observe
because we had to look through the
center of our own Galaxy an area known
as the zone of avoidance and one through
which our view is obscured by
Interstellar dust but we could see
through it with x-rays and this method
revealed a group of galaxies known as
the Noma cluster
but this alone wasn't enough to cover
the flow of galaxies and so scientists
watched the great attractor and came to
a remarkable conclusion it is itself in
motion towards a greater source of mass
650 million light years away lingered a
vast supercluster the largest for a
billion light years known as the shapley
supercluster this Leviathan contains the
mass of nearly 10 000 milky ways
[Music]
but that wasn't the end in 2017
researchers proposed a further element
dubbed the dipole repeller it is a large
void in almost the exact opposite
direction to the shapley supercluster
whereas sharply pulls this area of space
doesn't literally repel but its under
density means it can't overcome more
powerful gravitational forces and we are
sandwiched in the middle of this massive
Stellar flow almost a billion light
years across
though this may seem unbeatably large
this is only the beginning of the
structural Oddities that appear in the
large-scale mapping of the cosmos
one long-standing mystery that came to
light in the early 2000s was related to
the assumed homogeneity of our universe
the issue is fairly simple if you divide
the sphere of the CMB into four or eight
the top right is on average hotter than
the bottom left this effect disappears
if you divide the sky into more and more
pieces but for the quadrupole and the
octopole the angle of the line between
the hot part and the cold part matches
almost exactly with the plane of our
solar system this is a result so odd
that astronomers have named it the axis
of Evil because it threatens to break
our most fundamental ideas about the
universe why would the background of the
universe be aligned with our solar
system we don't know
nobody does the chief scientist of the
wmap telescope Charles Bennett thinks it
must be a coincidence I do think that
there is a bit of a psychological effect
people want to find unusual things but
even with new data from the Planck
telescope the effect is reproduced in
the words of Dominic Schwartz from the
University of bietherfeld in Germany for
a long time part of the community was
hoping that this would go away
but it hasn't
it is still totally unexplained
we understand so much about our physical
world we can shoot satellites into the
sky to take baby pictures of the
universe and use these images to rewind
the cosmos back to its first moments
between general relativity and the
standard model of particle physics we
think we have it all figured out but
there is much we do not know of course
in order to have structure in the
universe first the universe must begin
so how did we get our start
what's set off inflation
the answer to this question may be
hidden in the patterns of the universe's
largest structures one idea is that in
the primordial Universe there is a
roiling sea of dense vacuum energy and
it just takes something to set off an
inflationary bubble which then grows
into a universe but there's nothing
saying ours was the only inflationary
bubble perhaps another Universe formed
nearby just on the other side of the CMB
and if it went through inflation it
might collide with us
so this is one big mystery that the CMB
May yet hold the answer to great spots
in the sky resulting from collisions
with other bubble universes
we haven't seen anything yet but even
the possibility of evidence for
Multiverse theories is so sparse that
merely a method to find a glimmer of
proof is enough to excite scientists
[Music]
where are you the observable universe
lania Kea Virgo supercluster local group
Milky Way Orion arm local cavity local
Interstellar Cloud odd Cloud solar
system earth at every scale there is
structure there is order this structure
is governed by simple principles gravity
which is dominated by dark matter and
expansion which is now driven by dark
energy but which at one stage was the
result of inflation and yet these basic
principles turn matter and energy into
huge beautiful structures bathed in the
warm glow of the cosmic microwave
background radiation
Copernicus shapley's Vicky Rubin
zeldovich Peebles got
all of these scientists and the teams
that supported them have brought us this
far in uncovering its secrets
and yet despite all that we know there
are still Mysteries out there
Written in the Stars
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like And
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think thanks for watching and
we'll see you
time
[Music]